slava kem lil is waiting for us in the
arctic town of chersky
he's been applying for government grants
here but it's not where he feels at home
which is in the tundra with his reindeer
this is
[Music]
he has around 1 000 reindeer up near the
arctic ocean
around three hours from chersky and a
small team looking after them
some experienced herders others
teenagers from the local employment
center
it is a way of life intimately connected
with the environment
but climate change is forcing them to
adapt
there are depressions forming in the
tundra as the frozen ground or
permafrost thaws
so the reindeer have to take new
migratory routes
the snow cover changes too as
temperatures warm
winter rains on snow creating an icy
crust
which damages the reindeer's hooves and
muzzles as they forage for food
[Music]
[Music]
chemnil has had to cull a lot of
reindeer as a result
so that lame animals don't slow down the
herd
but the worst incident this year was
when a pack of 40 wolves attacked
killing a hundred reindeer
and the warming arctic is bringing big
predators closer
to us
[Music]
not
[Music]
for the reindeer herders it has always
been a case of adapting to nature's
requirements
but there is also the question of
adapting to the modern world
making the case for the young to stay
preserving the old way of life
in new circumstances
dynamagne sky news in the russian arctic
you